Okay.
What if we never invented this plastic once a revolutionary invention?
It's now filling up our oceans and killing thousands of whales,
birds,
turtles,
just how much plastic do we have around us?
What our life be less comfortable without it.
Any animal species could we save by getting rid of plastic debris?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if plastic was never invented.
Your plastic bag is actually chemically processed natural gas or oil.
You can tear it or burn it or throw it away when you're done with it,
but it won't decompose the way this loaf of bread will.
Since the 1950s we've created 6.3 billion tons of plastic.
9% of it,
we've recycled another 12% incinerated.
That leaves us with 4.9 billion tons of plastic waste.
If we could gather it all in one place,
this plastic mountain would be bigger than Mount Everest.
A lot of this waste ends up in the sea killing marine animals who mistake this
indigestible synthetic for food.
If we eliminated plastic from our lives,
we'd save hundreds of marine species from entanglement and plastic ingestion.
But what about us?
What would arm routine and be like without plastic?
How much do we depend on plastic anyway?
Even if you avoided using plastic containers to bring your lunch to work or bag
your groceries with reusable shopping bags,
you'd still be a far cry from going.
Absolutely plastic free plastic is everywhere.
Aluminum cans are lined with plastic resin.
Without it,
your cola would corrode it within three days.
Paper cups hide a thin layer of plastic too.
How do you think the keep the liquid inside?
No plastic would also mean no tea bags since their heat sealed with polyethylene
without plastic grocery shopping would look very different.
Our liquids would come in,
glass bottles,
our meats and cheese would be wrapped in paper.
You pack all your groceries and the paper bags or cardboard boxes.
One of the main benefits of plastic packaging is that it keeps feed fresh
longer.
Without this basic method of food preservation,
a lot of our food would need to be raised or grown locally and much of it would
only be available seasonally.
Organic waste would fill up the landfills and become our main environmental
concern.
Our closing would be limited to natural fibers,
no polyester socks,
nylon dresses or acrylic sweaters.
Say Goodbye to your fleece jacket,
heat and water resistant safety.
Where wouldn't exist either without the plastic needed for electrical
insulation,
there would be no inexpensive circuits to build your phone or computer.
Even early electronics in the 1910 [inaudible] who's one of the first plastics
bake light without any plastic,
we'd be stuck in 1870 still using nondurable and hazardous lacquer and rubber
insulator wires.
All the progress we've made with affordable electronics would never have
happened,
but at least we wouldn't be polluting the earth with disposable coffee cups,
water bottles,
toothbrushes,
and plastic stuff and 700 marine species wouldn't be affected by plastic debris.
If the thought of someone taking your plastic away doesn't ruin your day.
Consider moving to Kenya or Bangladesh where it's illegal to use plastic bags
and you might consider getting some of these slimy pets.
6,000 wax worms can eat up a plastic bag and just one hour
and 700 marine species wouldn't be affected by plastic debris.
If the thought of someone taking your plastic away doesn't ruin your day,
consider moving to Kenya or Bangladesh where it's illegal to use plastic bags
and you might consider getting some of these slimy pets.
6,000 wax worms can eat up a plastic bag and just one hour.